hey guys it is the 21st of January my
name's Jess McDowell and you attuned
into the games but news first up I've
got a story about Microsoft being in a
bit of hot water and hopefully someone
won't accuse me of being paid by Sony I
see the likelihood of that is pretty low
said hot water involves Microsoft having
launched a promotion that offers
machinima video partners payment for
publishing videos that feature the Xbox
one as reported by our technical
participants need to include at least 30
seconds of xbox one gameplay footage
mention the consoles name and have xbone
m13 tag to be eligible for the sweet
dough as you can imagine the
participants were told that they weren't
allowed to say anything negative about
xbox one any xbox one games on the [ __ ]
imma nor were they allowed to mention
the promotional agreement payment was
apparently limited to the first 1.25
million video views in the promotion
which caused it to conclude on january
16 the dude who leaked the agreement has
written a blog post about why he did so
where he also points out the machinima
coordinated similar promotions for pax
comic-con and III although they were for
a third of the payment that was offered
this time around a lot of you seem to
have some pretty strong opinions on this
one so let me know if you think this is
not okay or if you're on Microsoft side
here next up resident evil 4 also known
as one of the good ones is coming to PC
in HD and it's doing so at 60 frames per
second the ultimate HD Edition will
feature steam support and according to
capcom it's sharper with an improved
experience for modern machines which
sort of makes sense since the game is 9
years old the survival horror game will
set you back twenty bucks and while the
price isn't obscene most of you in the
comments just seem to be a bit fed up
with Capcom milking the series for all
it's worth games but user quake II
weighs in with President evil for
ultimate HD Edition don't you think they
went a bit overboard with the name
what's next Resident Evil fabulous shade
of light
uber texture mega edition number five do
you agree that this edition is a bit
unnecessary or will you be picking it up
for yourself leave me your thoughts dead
rising 3 is getting smacked with a 13
gigabyte update which even had xbox
studio manager Mike you borrow saying
holy Capcom hasn't told us exactly why
the update is gargantuan but one guess
is that it contains updates or content
preparing for the DLC pack which just so
happens to learn today but you'll have
to update whether you actually decide to
get your hands on it or not what do you
guys think is in the giant update you
can let me know in the comments down
below or on my twitter where i'm at just
my stomach those are all the good things
that i have for you today but be sure
join me again same time and place
tomorrow where i'll have more of that
musi stuff i'm just mcdonald and i'll
see you again then